the kids they go back to school next
month and our friends at silver state
schools credit union the sponsors of
this next segment want to make sure your
kids go back prepared and they're going
to let you know how you can help
so good to have you back on las vegas
now scott i can't believe the kids are
going back to school next month and
silver state schools credit union you
guys are doing a back to school drive so
tell us a little bit about it and how we
can participate our annual back to
school drive supports our local
community through the silver state
schools credit union people over profit
or what we call the pop foundation and
our members have always been very
generous uh when donating supplies
however anyone in our community can
participate by visiting any one of our
10 branch locations to drop off any new
school supplies and so kind of an
emphasis on new
and we're accepting all types of school
supplies pencils pens notebooks but
especially backpacks those are always a
favorite for the children and they're
very much needed so
these supplies will go directly to
benefit our focus schools and those are
rex bell elementary and stanford
elementary as well as the girls athletic
leadership or gal school
and to find a branch location near you
to drop off your donations please visit
silverstatecu.com
locations i love that you guys do this
always helping out the community
something that's really cool my
daughter's just the other day they got
their uh statements from silver state
schools credit union because i'm a
member they're also members and i love
how they go through and they they try to
make sure like oh what did i make an
interest and it's really neat so why is
it so important
for parents to teach financial literacy
and how does silver state schools credit
union help get them started yeah i'm i'm
so glad you asked that mercedes you know
silver state schools credit union really
puts an emphasis on financial literacy
and financial wellness and so literacy
is kind of the
what's needed the wellness is really the
goal of getting there and so they're so
valuable at every stage of life and we
believe it's important to instill
positive financial habits at an early
age
this in turn helps parents nurture
lifelong financial
skills for their children positive
habits can build on to rewarding uh
children for really simple tests like
such as earning five dollars for
completing chores or completing homework
assignments on anything that a parent
can kind of think of and as children
earn these rewards they can be deposited
into their own junior savings account at
silver state schools credit union we
offer these junior accounts to help
children
gain valuable financial skills while
making sure that their savings accounts
grow
not only do the parents gain access to a
hands-on tool to teach positive
financial habits but it can also help
the parents prepare for uh college
education expenses by providing access
to edu or educational savings accounts
which we have um and to learn more about
these junior accounts i invite parents
to visit silverstatecu.com
and uh and you could take a look and and
find these uh the the junior savings
accounts as well as the educational
savings accounts
thank you again to silver state schools
credit union for sponsoring this segment
for more information give them a call
702-733-8820 or visit silverstatecu.com
it is